und darin kann ich jetzt mein auto
parken und habe direkt daneben mein bett
das schauen wir uns jetzt etwas und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
will eigentlich auch gar nicht lange
gelagert
wobei schaut mal ich war ja im urlaub
ich bin extrem braun geworden finde ich
im gesicht und meine nase ist bisschen
rot wir fahren jetzt zu einem hotel wo
ich meine also das hätte ich jetzt total
blöd an wo man sein auto im zimmer
tragen kann
ich fand das so interessant dass ich mir
gedacht da musste video zu machen wie
gesagt ich bin schon zu spät deswegen
nehmen euch mit
und ich hoffe es gefällt euch ich bin
mal gespannt was mich erwartet also man
kann da wirklich sein eigenes auto mit
dem zimmer nehmen
da gibt es noch viel mehr zu sehen
anscheinend und wir fahren jetzt mal hin
wir sehen uns gleich im auto alte leute
die sonne ball hat heute wieder so krass
jetzt habe ich hier vor mir ein
taxifahrer schaffst du es hoffentlich
leute auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt
schon meine zimmer karte für das zimmer
und erfahren wir jetzt mal rein ich kann
direkt mit meinem auto wurde ins zimmer
fahren und da vorne könnte jetzt auch
schon sehen motor world v8 hotel da muss
ich hin
okay ich bin echt mal gespannt was mich
erwartet es sieht auf jeden fall von
außen schon ultra gaal auskommen da die
ganzen autos okay hier geht's jetzt
recht
richtiger deckel so 14 jahre
apropos
der bauer
ok ich muss ich gerade mal schauen genau
ich habe hier heute glaube ich die
nummer drei suite 3 ja das müsste meine
sein sieht schon mal ein eis aus
so dann wollen wir mal raus ich habe
hier jetzt meine karte für die garage 3
und ich hoffe damit für mich da ist
irgendwie rein okay leute wir schauen
jetzt mal ob er das hier mit auffliegen
jetzt hält man die karte und einfach wir
vor
und dann geht hoffentlich ja und da drin
kann ich jetzt mein auto parken und habe
direkt daneben mein bett das schauen wir
uns gleich machen
ok also wie man schon sehen ich habe
sogar die ford garage bekommen oder das
vorzimmer da man foto die haben wir über
ganz viele verschiedene bilder von ford
und das zimmer ist direkt da und das
geht automatisch jetzt wieder zu hören
ich hoffe mit dem weg kann ich euch auch
in mein zimmer einfach so dass gar nicht
abgeschlossen
man kommt hier also nur über die garage
rhein in dem er mit seinem auto
reinfährt anders nicht und ich denke
einfach welches hotel spa hat dieses
feature habe ich noch nie gesehen
ok ab ins zimmer und klimatisiert also
was ein echter neese man sitzt hier auf
dem bett und da steht ein auto das heißt
wenn ich schlafen gehe kann ich mein
auto ankommen
das müssen wir glaube ich mir das
nochmal film stalker ich würde sagen
bevor ich euch jetzt den rest vom zimmer
zeige ich habe gehört hier gibt es so
eine ganze motor world also alles voll
mit irgendwelchen geilen autos und die
kann ich alle sehen wenn ich einfach aus
dieser tür raus ihr ob das so stimmt
werden wir jetzt sehen ich bin auf jeden
fall ultra gespannt und ist sie auch
oder
also ich bin auf jeden fall jetzt schon
mal ein paar autos ich würde sagen wir
gehen einfach mal rum weil ich glaube da
hinten geht's auf jeden fall noch
deutlich weiter also gibt es anscheinend
auch restaurants wie das hier zum
beispiel okay da kann ich wieder was
essen und alter wir sind jetzt auf jeden
fall schon autos die mir deutlich mehr
gefallen ich würde sagen bevor ich jetzt
die weitergehe
klingt erst mal einen kleinen überblick
von dem ganzen hier und ich muss aber
erstmal mehr überbieten
[Musik]
gegründet
da ist mit dem rasen
leute was auch noch gast ist also ich
muss erst mal ganz ehrlich sagen für
formel 1 habe ich mich früher nicht so
viel interessiert wie für fußball aber
hier gibt es einfach genau vor meiner
tür vom hotelzimmer eine ganze
ausstellung von michael schumacher mit
all seinen autos hier gefahren ist alle
anzüge alle helme und da muss schon
sagen damit hätte ich jetzt überhaupt
nicht gerechnet so was mal in echt zu
sehen wir können ja mal kurz hier
durchgehend ich habe auch bis jetzt erst
einmal in meinem leben so einen echten
formel 1 wagen gesehen
und hier stehen jetzt einfach so 20
stück also wie schon gesagt ich war
jetzt nicht der größte formel 1 fan aber
das ist selbst für mich gerade mega
interessant das war jetzt glaube ich die
autos medina angefangen hat und davor da
ist auch sein erstes cover das von ihr
aussehen
wir gehen das wollte ich früher auch mal
mega gerne machen wir so ein eigenes
kart zu haben aber irgendwie haben mir
meine eltern das nie gekauft wenn ihr
das seht kann ich nicht gut und man sich
auch noch mal sagen wollte wenn du jetzt
immer hier runter films ihr könnt ja
jetzt mal in den kommentaren schätzen
was alle autos die hier stehen zusammen
wert sind und ich versuche mal den
richtigen wert rauszukriegen und der der
diesen wert errät kriegt eins dieser
autos nicht spaß aber du hast dann auf
jeden fall gut okay wir haben es auch
schon halb neun
ich würde sagen wir haben sich ins
zimmer ich zeige euch nochmal schnell
alles und dann gibt es auch gleich noch
meinen nachbarn das ist nämlich die
lamborghini k suite soll sich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen verrückt aber da
kann man dann rein wenn man den eigenen
lamborghini hat und hier gerne schlafen
möchte sowie das verstand und ich bin
mal gespannt ob er auch einer drinsteht
wenn man jetzt den fernseher anmacht ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich jetzt fernsehen
schauen soll oder ob ich mein auto
angucken soll das muss man sich mal
vorstellen liegt unserem hotel und kann
sein auto sehen und hier oben weil wir
sind ja im vorzimmer ist einfach dieses
muster ins foyer auf jeden fall auch
mein eigenes gemacht wenn wir hier ins
bad gehen haben wir einfach das
aktuellste muster modell an der wand und
da das klo
also ich muss wirklich sagen so verrückt
ist duell zimmer hatte ich noch nie ich
könnte ja auch gern mal in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr
verrücktestes hotelzimmer war der mir
jemand ob sich das mit diesem hier
messen kann und jetzt freue ich mich
eigentlich sehr auf das nachbarzimmer
weil da wurde mir gesagt das ist ja auf
jeden fall mal reinschauen so ich hatte
jetzt nämlich sogar das glück dass ich
mir vom hotellier zugang verschaffen
durfte wir haben jetzt die lamborghini k
street und die schauen wir uns jetzt mal
jetzt bin ich mal wirklich gespannt vom
thema her sieht das ja gleich aus malta
da würde ich tauschen
[Musik]
geht die alarmanlage haben wenn ich das
versuchen versuchen bevor hier ist etwas
kaputt mache schönes auto mir genau das
immer wieder meint man sonst selten so
leute wären jetzt mittlerweile ungefähr
halb zwölf ich schlafe ja für eine nacht
und ich wollte euch jetzt nochmal hier
als letzte schrott meinen ausblick
zeigen nein es geht nicht um alkohol als
letztes bild hier mal mein austritt
zeigen weil ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich bin wirklich überwältigt schaut euch
das mal an ihr habt glaube ich eben
schon mal irgendwo gesehen ich kann
einfach mein auto sehen das wird auch
noch angestrahlt hier läuft noch ein
bisschen ahnung was das ist rtl halt
dann würde ich sagen gute nacht auto
wurden auch wenn euch auch jetzt
schlafen werden sie aus ich hoffe dass
wir dadurch gefallen lassen nach oben da
steckt man die adresse von dem laden
hier ab und das war es